you can't bury my head oh yeah Oh super
speed jetpack speeds of 100 miles per
hour
we're going up use me this seems kind of
Oh
I presented my a stand they took full
advantage of it hello the hardest game
no it is quite difficult because you're
such a bottle front wheel yeah yeah yeah
don't find a way over it land again oh
oh ok ok
oh my goodness
gravy this is fantastic helicopter fun
this is the new character
oh how do you like it nope nope nope
wait hold on I'm still gonna use with
this I don't know how this new character
works try to survive well don't you know
that I am the most professional of
survivors up what does this even
supposed to be hard
they're not even throwing things at me
here dad
I got a weapon now what happened my way
I'm not even gonna worry about it oh my
oh no oh you killed yourself that's too
bad oh no I lost my kid yeah oh you all
suck so bad why are you so awful at
living and doing things you dumbasses no
Santa I'm coming oh come on I got ya
Levante right in your ding dongs ah my
heads right in your ding dong now grab
the harpoon this time I have warning
thank you very much nice
spinning weapons oh I see this is
supposed to be Lisa
Oh get out of my way get out of my way
no girl Carrie come on come on that's
all you need to do well practically
cheating on this level lightsaber duel
dismounting grab oh I'll dismount grab
come Ariel bits I'm gonna get you oh you
got my ass but I'll get your face
do-do-do-do-do-do didn't yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh you are trying to cut
I gotta be more careful okay I gotta be
really careful anything about this
all right you could ease one another
impossible level so try not to get us
getify what was that kiddies did you say
something it's something happen
titties ha ha ha pitties get off my face
it's not the time for that
yeah we cares about kitties don't do
real good about it victory
there's a little tires will deliver all
those presents to the Bradford fitting
all over the world but thank you for
watching
don't worry about daring to cower water
will die with your rambling or friends
you hold your life Dan's gonna hold dear
this bottle of booze and this manganese
will bugger